welcome back to the rockstars I'm Eric
Foss and Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
will feature a new era of Groot who is
introduced to the Guardians of the
Galaxy holiday special known as swole
Groot our man looks like he's been doing
some two days at the nowhere gym or
maybe joining the god of thunder on a
muscle building plan or maybe just
sharing toothbrushes with Hulk whenever
he went to Cigar based on the fluid
transfer logic of She-Hulk for real
though what's going on with small group
how Groot swole why Groot swole I'm
gonna explain some stuff you might not
have known about this group's biology
his anatomy and how he's actually a far
more complex and mysterious creature
with perhaps a deeper role to play in
Guardians volume 3. also you can come
meet me live at La Comic-Con this Sunday
December 4th with other new rockstars
hosts it's gonna be a great time come
hang out with us okay compared to the
last time we saw Groot his physiology is
certainly bulked out wide plates of bark
now stretch across his chest like
pectoral muscles and shoulders kind of
looks a lot like football players
shoulder pads this bark even seems to be
outgrowing his skeletal structure
leaving chunky gaps between the joints
like notice how rocket and Cosmos tree
decorate slide right through the gap of
his arm in the post-credit scene and I
would say the spark also looks
reminiscent of armor armor that angles
upward from the shoulders yes armor worn
by celestials that could be important
I'll come back to it and by the way many
have thoughts well Groot was a practical
suit but no no James Gunn has confirmed
he is 100 CGI from the 2014 Guardians of
the Galaxy film groot's Homeworld was
listed as Planet X in the comic sees the
species known as Flora colossi these
tree like beans are ruled over by Arbor
Masters who endow each new generation
with photonic knowledge via
photosynthesis which is pretty much all
the accumulated knowledge of every past
generation making every one of these
things a freaking genius and while
groot's vocal utterances sound to us
like the simple phrase of I am Groot in
the comics the inhuman Maximus mad
clarified that Groot is actually saying
a variety of things and others who hear
him initially are just oblivious to the
nuances and tonal variations of his
speech now to be clear when Groot died
in the 2014 film he was not reborn or
cloned as the baby group Baby Groot is
the original groot's progeny his
offspring his son of being with a
completely different life in a
completely different mind and no passed
on memories from his father James gonna
decide to clarify this quite a bit on
Twitter recently when people ask why
swole Groot is developing differently
than the original group the original
group having an adult build that was
much lankier Gunn has even elaborated in
a few interviews like with Entertainment
Weekly so we also get like the latest
edition of Groot so we had baby group
angsty teen group what is the approx age
of this group and what do we call him
he's full Groot
he is like jacked he's jacked man he's
jacked I think he's like he's a
Collegiate like excitable football Groot
I think you can see now that he's very
much a different group than the original
Groot he's grown into somebody quite
different and he's becoming his own uh
not person his own group and with Daniel
Chen on the ringers mint Edition podcast
it looks like it's been bulking season
for Groot but what stage of his
development do we find this the swole
group you could call him in this yeah
yeah he's also he started out as y a
group young adult group right the
Collegiate group you know I think that
you can start to see there's a very
different group than uh the Groot in the
first movie he really is groot's progeny
he's not group he's Groot just not that
great and you get to see that he's
developing a little bit differently he's
not a skinny guy he's a bulky guy that's
his natural body type he just started to
fill out when he got through his teen
years this crude is a very exuberant
group he's very excited about things
he's got a lot of energy he's ready to
go face the world you know hasn't been
disappointed by you know his his 20s as
many people are ah so we're starting to
see a recurring description from James
Gunn on this age of Groot specifically
Collegiate athletic a bit Broly
optimistic obsuberant early 20s but not
burned by his 20s this people in their
30s are actually back in the year 2020
Vin Diesel did an interview with Brandon
Davis at comicbook.com and had another
way of describing this era of Groot I
only have two words uh about
that character and it is Alpha group at
the time we all wondered
was referring to as Alpha Groot stupid
Diesel's basically saying I'm already an
alpha I'm then I'm already an alpha I
can't do it I'm already enough also why
didn't she Hulk invite me to a barbecue
I invented that family that hurt my
throat now it can be hard to watch
actors and not immediately think hey I'd
like to have gorgeous skin and hair just
like they do well with geology you can
geology is a four-time award-winning
personalized skincare company
recognizing Men's Health Esquire and ask
men grooming Awards with over 6 000 5
Star reviews and they've recently
expanded to offer products for pretty
much whatever you need like if you need
Hair Care use geology's co-wash it's a
specially formulated cream cleanser that
removes buildup and cleanses the hair
without the big lather or harsh
ingredients of typical shampoo and for
the rest of your shower routine you can
use their body washes they're free of
harsh ingredients smell great and are
refillable and for after the shower
protect your skin from environmental
stressors with vitamin C plus e for
Relic serum to keep your skin looking
young and healthy and then a bit of the
dermatologist tested aluminum free
deodorant that quite honestly smells
great right now for a limited time
geology is hooking our audience up with
an absolutely insane offer if you use
the code new rockstars they will give
you an additional 70 off their
award-winning skincare trial set this
discount stacks on top of their current
sale prices and there's also an
additional bonus offer on one of their
brand new skin hair and body products of
your choice when you add it to your
trial with the holidays right around the
corner geology has you covered check out
their awesome gift sets featuring all of
your favorite geology products to get
started just click the link in the
description take a 30 second diagnostic
quiz and their team of dermatologists
will design a personalized routine just
for you that ships directly to your door
also that was the same interview where
diesel revealed that Groot would appear
in Thor love and thunder and in that
movie Groot was still in his adolescent
Groot Anatomy form from Avengers
Infinity war and Adventures end game and
when asked about the timeline of all
this James Gunn said that in his mind
the Guardians were with Thor for only a
few weeks and he applied to the
Guardians holiday today's special and
guardians of galaxy vol 3 are set after
that and in that time since they have
used their money for mercenary gigs to
buy nowhere from The Collector and set
it up as their new home base and as
someone who was lucky to see the
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 trailer
footage from Comic-Con I can tell you
swole Groot is the era of Groot that we
will see in that film there is a shot in
that footage where Groot and Peter Quill
are back to back their arms outstretched
and shoot out and groot's hands his arms
and his shoulders are the same bulky
proportion now from James Gunn's
interviews it sounds like he updated
Groot into swole Groot deliberately to
show that this Groot is a different
being in the original group not his
clone but his son his Destiny is not to
regrow back into the OG group from the
2014 Guardians film that Groot is dead
something different has happened in the
life of this group and what is that
because what we have instead is a new
group with different life experiences
inaccurate when you think about it has
been pretty consistent across the films
he's creative and crafty like he made
art of the Guardians in the I am Groot
short and then the holiday special he
quickly made dioramas for each of them
this group loves to dance he danced to
Mr Blue Sky in volume 2 and he danced to
the old 97s now he's the only person in
nowhere who danced along to that he's
also a gamer he played the defender
handheld game in Infinity war and he
hops with excitement to get an original
game boy now so why is this Groot swole
while the other group wasn't I think it
comes back to that concept of photonic
knowledge that I brought up earlier
Groot is a product of photosynthetic
influences the OG group was a
beneficiary of photonic Knowledge from
his Arbor Masters but that hasn't been
the case for this group this grid has
been cut off from his Homeworld his
family instead has been rocket Drax
quill the rest of the Guardians of the
Galaxy so his personality and his nature
are more a product of their influences
and his cellulose has been absorbing
their light and I don't use the term
light just poetically here though it's
fine if you would prefer to just leave
this as a matter of well Groot is swole
because the self-care he learned from
overly fit weirdos like Drax and Peter
Quill rocket may not have been his
father but he was his daddy really I
think Groot possesses a biological
function a form of photosynthesis that
can converts radiation emitted from
nearby life forms into his anatomical
structure that's why the OG Groot
emitted glowing spores when he gave his
life and it's why when ego described the
celestial Gene that he hoped would pass
down to his offspring Peter Quill and we
just learned in the holiday special his
daughter mantis ego said these words one
after the other they failed me not one
of them carried the celestial genes
until you Peter out of all my spawn
only you carry the connection to light
light like the balls of light that he
appeared well played catch with and how
did Meredith quill describe ego and
Peter on her deathbed sound like your
daddy
light again therefore I believe that
brute has unlike his father grown into
this swole group form because he has
spent most of his life in the company of
at least two Celestial Offspring pure
quill and mantis who have made higher
degrees of cosmic radiation radiation
which endowed group with a different
kind of photonic knowledge to make him
act more like freaking Andy Dwyer and an
oversensitive empath while
photosynthetically giving him the wooden
form of celestial armor let me know your
thoughts on swole group and follow me on
Tick Tock Hive Instagram and Twitter at
EA boss follow the new rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]